de là à un membre de l'équipe de tmp ça
vient d'en haut membre de l'équipe de
tpm p&o loge castaldi a fait un bon
accueil à april benayoun juste après lui
avoir fait une biche chaleureuse
benjamin a déclaré elle est mieux sur un
stack en vrai
elle est magnifique en plus après les
manifs il est magnifique il ya poucave
ça papa regarde si tu ne fais pas moi
mais j'aurais pu
mais il dit aux élus aussi cela raconte
en loge away c'est vrai maintenant parce
que comme vous lui avez dit récemment
qu'il faisait de bonnes audiences il est
insupportable et c'est pas voulu à me
dire vous lui avez dit tout à l'heure
encore et vous lui avez dit récemment
pour son émission 6 à 7 et donc du coup
c'est vrai qui pète un peu les plombs il
juge les gens il a
vu il avait une gare j'ai même dit j'ai
tué montiel
c'était vraiment
effrayant c'est que c'est vrai vous avez
misé tout le monde tienne ça ne va pas
du tout et concernant appris d'elles est
très très mal et c'est vrai que parfois
il ya une différence entre la
wilaya pas différent ça y est la
différence maintenant que je le voyais
pas différent du mal à merci elle est
très belle et incroyable très belle est
ce que c'est votre style april oui
j'aime bien
c'est plus votre style delphine nous
apprîmes delphine dard et qui a pris le
nom était la
[Applaudissements]
face au succès de tpm people qu'il
considère comme énorme à considère lui
comme élan mathieu aurait parlé à la
direction des sémites pour que face à
bas deviennent face à mama
[Rires]
la direction n'aurait pas donné suite
c'est une source de guillaume genton
mathieu nage en plein délire il a déjà
pensé à une date pour la première de
face à my soul tout le monde avec ses en
coulisses et il veut absolument recevoir
mimie mathy
j'adore mimie mathy mois donc voilà
l'info n'est qu'à moitié vrai ce que
j'ai proposé à la chaîne pour le moment
mais ils vont vous en parler parce que
vous avez un avis consultatif que ça
intéresse tout le monde ce que j'ai
proposé à la chaîne c'est d'alterner
aussi le jeudi soir avec benhaim comme
elle a deux prime que je fasse les deux
autres prime du jeu des supporters des
autres et
je vous dirai d'abord pour vous avez
joué mais pour l'instant pour l'instant
il va falloir vraiment vous fassiez vos
preuves parce que pour l'instant mais ça
y est c'est le prof comme chroniqueur
ici pour l'instant raymond on est
d'accord que comme animateur il est
encore en jachère avoue moi vous vous
moquez de moi quand je vous dis ça pour
moi un animateur jama 26 noms
des primes c'est vrai je crois que tu as
raison
je vous regarde eu tant de photos mais
quand on m'a bombers ce viol et ça y est
c'est qu'on n'y est bien c'est pas de
manteau l'espace jean déprime pourquoi
aller chercher mon fils top
[Applaudissements]
ils nous emmerdent bien nous emmerdent
ah tiens parlons de votre liste j'ai un
truc que je voulais vous montrer pour
les pour tous les parents et les ados
qui l'on garde vous savez que pompes à
l'école je vous avais prépare un truc
mais perd un truc qui souffrent en ce
moment c'est que qu'est ce qu'ils font
ils préparent ils font leur test là
autotests way et
si vous prenez du soda oui je vais
prendre du soda venez voir voilà j'avais
d'ailleurs mais il me préparer là si je
crois de syspro du coca bafin du soda la
cola on va dire que je le mets mais non
sur le texte la dot s not au test de m
voilà je mets une petite goutte ouais
regardez vous allez voir vous allez voir
vous allez voir ce que ça fait et
normalement on va voir si on est positif
ou pas non ils font ça au lieu ils
mettent du coca et ils disent un papa
maman je suis positivement elle encourt
alors je vais le faire regardez là je
veux faire le test car voilà il est
super brillant mais c'est vrai et là bas
et je vais le faire il ya aussi une
autre boisson s'est déjà pressé
le citron j'ai déjà pressé
les nouvelles idées regardez vous allez
voir vous allez voir on va attendre et
vous allez voir tout à l'heure je vais
vous montrer que vous montrez les tests
ça c'est vraiment c'est incroyable on
leur tour bureau cet après midi eh ben
normalement le test quand la tête va
être positif c'est fou pas vous allez
voir je vous montrerai ça tout à l'heure
pour l'instant vous le dépressif comment
ça va qu'est ce qui la faisait très fort
c'est pourquoi est très fort parce que
mon fils m'a appelé au nom non justement
parce que une classe à côté de la sienne
il alterna la crise à côté de la sienne
qu'à contacter 1,4 qu'ovide dans le
lycée ils ont viré tout le monde du
lycée ils ont mis tout le monde dans la
rue en fête les mondes comme ils ont
passé les brevets de black blanc là des
examens de blanc à bandes blanches
c'est un examen et il fallait que je le
récupère et c'est pour ça que j'arrive à
l'instant en retard parce que j'ai été
chercher et c'est par rapport au ps et
pcr gt26 juger par sa pour mon émission
oui oui ma part ça c'est vraiment gentil
avec toi on ne chauffe pas parce que
t'es pas un animateur
je sais bien
tony kart est comme ça un animateur vous
l'avez regardé samedi j'ai regardé ce
qui lui manquait ce qui me garde et
maintenant qu'est-ce qui la question du
manque début a été très bon quand il a
dit c'est sponsorisé par exane axe que
les mauvaises sage et bien c'est pas
drôle après je n'ai pas compris pourquoi
tout le monde parle et en même temps il
a pas su ça respect alors il a un
problème de poids de sa manne d'autorité
de poignard regarder tout le monde parle
et la nuit et lui rigoler comme c'était
croyez cherche à regarder quand vous
dites chute on se tait quand ma gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui vous attendez combien pour son
deuxième numéro tpm et alors il a fait
comme nationale 520 sata de 160 go 1
3583 mine mais pendant sa mesure non non
non
438 230 euros qu il
ya un phénomène et je le dis j'ai un
phénomène qui se passe souvent sur la
deuxième il ya une petite baisse
c'est normal et j'ai peur qu'ils fassent
480 comme l'avion à la 83è d'arriver
bientôt
annoncer compte gens de 80 90 alors
qu'alan gps condor est ce qu'on peut se
faire à paris ouais si je suis à plus de
600 al alawi situe à plus de 600 oui
même quelque chose
je fais les caries non mais je vous
offre déjà des missions que ça allait me
faire jouer les arbitres essaient de
faire déneiger ou dire
s'il vous plaît on sera content quand
vous ferez plus d'un million alors voilà
connerie il faut aux normes et d'accueil
la fia écoute moi bien du lundi au
vendredi au fait combien tu as la marque
en vue seule ma voix la paix dont vous
avez la marque ben vrai ça marque
vraiment vous fait non on sera on fera
un cadeau quand il fera plus d'un
million et à tête l'homme a jamais de
cadeau
je vais vous dire cette semaine je sors
650 milles en 1650 650 je le sens bien
attention une source guillaume genton
aulas raymond à dingue et april benayoun
dans les coulisses il lui a filé son
numéro un c'est faux et c'est vrai bref
elle aurait tous
je sais pas conduire des ferrari moi je
me serais
jamais donné mon numéro de portable
récent numéro l'abominable hommes de
régis a encore frappé il a demandé son
snap et il a même promis qu'ils eurent
ferait passer l'élection miss france
grâce à sylvie tellier qui est
soi-disant son ami je lui ai même pas
parlé alors pas plus que moi je te
laissait tranquille avec delphine et
janvier qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ya rejet
porter les bagages de delphine jusqu'à
son taxi j'ai failli rentrer que définir
soir j'ai pas j'ai dit non j'ai dû aux
taxes à grands traits j'ai parlé puisque
v veut jouer à ça tu sais je suis un bon
je me remets sur delphine soit christian
et voilà le remarquer un des deux villes
n'a que des beaux gosses et
celle au miel et les abeilles
des plus bas de
gamme à prix n'est pas votre cas
pourtant ces combats ce que vous étiez
vraiment sa gamme a
subi face à guillaume maritime ça va les
gars
qui fait dérailler un petit tremblement
de terre
c'est quoi y'a un mec qui fait des
travaux à côté au corps ce qu'il ya un
bruit de foule à côté on va voir c'est
juste un mec qui lève les stores avec
qui se relayent c'est le producteur
d'émissions et nous emmerder par
matthieu delormeau s'est installé un
bureau sans savoir qu'il s'agissait de
celui du producteur du 6 à 7 quand celui
ci lui a demandé de bien vouloir
récupérer son bureau mathieu lui a dit
désolé j'étais persuadé que tu étais
l'un des chauffeurs de cyril
messina mai mais je ne vais pas souvent
h2o et j'y suis allé je suis rentré 9
n'est plus je suis rentré dans ce bureau
et c'est vrai j'ai vu ce gars ont compté
qu'ils mèneront aux chauffeurs j'ai
confondu et je pensais pas tout
électrique est alors alors sans eau je
suis je ne pensais pas que 6 à 7m un
producteur voilà la méchante alors je
vous dis la vérité moi non plus
c'est ça c'est normal
c'est moi qui tu vois des tâches allait
très bien il est très bon c'est vrai que
merrill ils méritent des producteurs tu
vois un verrou tu t'installes alors les
chéris durant leurs deux semaines de
télétravail à punta cana projet d'alcine
projet delphine aurait consommé
seulement deux fois à son retour
delphine a déclaré être dégoûté un ex de
delphine à la gauche de cyril
non il paraît que vous êtes quoi utaka
là vous êtes resté 15 jours vous allez
vous êtes quelque chose que deux fois
qui à dessein bah c'est sûr ça
en fait pour échapper au devoir conjugal
roger aurait simulé une grosse migraine
ensuite il attrapé un gros coup de
soleil c'est très frais y aurait mangé
toutes sortes de fruits exotiques pour
attraper une bonne grosse touristes à
passer grand chose malheureusement alors
non pas une société très bien et vous
savez que quand on est en vacances et
qui fait chaud bas ça stimule tous donc
c'est super c'est pour ça que ça nous
arrache moi j'ai vu les vidéos la savane
et même dégoûtés des
babys me dégoûte les vacances ça
rapproche les gens part ça le mercredi
kelly et mathieu un refus d'entrer en
plateau quand castaldi anime la dernière
partie du 6 à 7 pour ne pas apparaître
comme vulgaire chroniqueur vin casta
ça nous regarde c'est pas vraiment aidé
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr c'est vrai mais
la vérité mais tenniel et germinal
mercredi bafoussam bien sûr
c'est en revanche benali minière est
avec moi dans la loge et elle a dit non
non géré après je suis discuter que si
vite c'est doux
avec moi pourquoi est-ce que matthieu 10
impasse complète mathieu calcule son
salaire par rapport à leur nombre de
bateaux savoie qui ces dix minutes en
plus il va demander de l'argent en plus
jamais vous aviez vous avez une phrase
très vrai qu'on a le droit à chaque fois
qu'il fait dix minutes en plus il va
demander de l'argent plus demandés oui à
voir non
mais son cas aulas qui se passe chez
castel devant nous
mais ça me concerne oui
la styliste
du scellier ou pas ah oui mais lively le
toit parce que il sert il a déclaré en
off que pour 1 milliard d'euros
oh là là
tu attends beaucoup
martine le feuillet
et
nous on a deux en quoi tous les jours
pendant deux ans
combien
1 milliard pour améliorer ses plans mais
c'est pas passé mais c'était c'est vrai
tu
es mon ami mais j'étais là c'est moi je
le peux brunck et aux quatre
[Applaudissements]
jours deux ans pour une qui aucun way
deux ans mais ron kg saxe
oui oui vous avez 10 1 milliards si
bien qu'il a je dois dire que c'est vrai
là et daniel est folle de joie de l a
plus qu elle trouvait notamment qui aime
et sait nous écoute
moi alors je me casse je vois que ça
tire à balles réelles attention là
guillaume a fait un canular à castaldi
en se faisant passer pour un cadre de
tf1 il m'a dit
il lui dit il le dit avec le retour de
flavie flament sur tf1 on voudrait aussi
vous réengager au même tarif qu'en 2010
benjamin aurait accepté ce gilbert dès
lors c'est vrai nom génère des sous
c'est vrai et il a même ajouté qu' on
pourra vous le confirmer dès le coup de
fil il a dit je vous propose également
une série télé j'ai un jeu ils voulaient
recyclé cash island et il a bien il a
bien calculé incroyable je laisse
guillaume le dire un truc incroyable qui
nous soutiennent yeux bleus ghazi je
suis prêt à commencer dès lundi
alors mais si je me réfère serrer la
main sur le coeur au nom de notre amitié
est ce que vous pensez une seconde alors
le coeur vous le sentez avec vos seins
ou pas
la main sur le coeur ses prétentions pas
s'arranger coûte un nom la main sur le
coeur si rim entre vous et moi oui au
nom de notre amitié après le sud est dit
eh oui pensez vous une seconde que ces
deux horribles bonhomme 3 3 tt tenait
aussi toi non mais indigne et immédiat
josse et tf1 m'appelle je pars dans la
minute web
[Applaudissements]
que ce soit vrai oui
[Rires]
4 alors je vous dirais non mais alors
moi et casta me connaît alors ça ça ne
me fait pas du tout
s'il est heureux moi ce que je vois
c'est qu'il soit heureux si les plus
heureux là bas moi par lendemain la tf1
m'appelle je suis de jiri jamais voilà
je le dis oui mes bébés richer et
brillant comme vous êtes est ce que vous
pensez vous avez vraiment des amis quoi
c'est bien parce que quand on est riche
et puissant comme vous mais les gens
viennent forcément par opportunité
et un ami benjamin
avec naïve et une amie ni toi là raymond
est un ami guillaume est un ami oui
géraldine est une amie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non non et non maintien du coup mathieu
une connexion ça voilà mais que j'aime
beaucoup moi j'ai connu ce que vous
connaissez quand j'étais au top à nrj 12
mais gens viennent forcément tu fais tu
acceptes de cyril d'un poème de melon
toi
non mais non mylène carrière magnifique
vrai sens
du comique et kate
enfin
à harry fait qu'est à oui alors la chine
vers d'ailleurs c'est moche à russia
sentant que cyril à un regain d'amour
pour daniel moreau lionel stan le
directeur général de la société à
château qui est un ami je reviens comme
par miracle en plateau et redit bonjour
à un côté de la table qu'il avait
complètement boycotter ouais et ça c'est
vrai ça fait beaucoup de peine alors moi
ça ne change pas puisque il ne m'a
jamais dit bonjour
mais ils ne venaient plus du tout saluer
isabelle isabelle en était très amer
parce qu'elle m'avait dit je laime abel
qui reviendra la semaine prochaine voilà
il ne disait plus jamais bonjour de ce
côté là et comme il est bon il est très
bien lionel mais il est opportuniste il
pense à sa carrière et d'études pas du
tout est bon très bien et comme vous
pouvez le demander et comme inazuma
daniel était de nouveau en faut et bien
il vient dire bonjour maintenant de ce
côté-là il croit pas du tout lui
demander
quoi m'insurge en faux quand lionel
vient il bonjour je m'insurge enfourché
la série j'ai dit alors
dit des trucs ça me parle de ton fils
ton sac c'est d'essayer pas et c'est pas
de faire des effets de fils jonathan
béland de l'islam et grammaticales mans
et c'est pas bien des usagers des je
suis allé chercher mon fils je suis
revenu bonjour à tous comment allez vous
[Applaudissements]
je m'assure gentil non non ça n'existe
pas ça n'existe pas oui
fois que lionel vient il dit bonjour ce
côté là ce cas mr d'accord lionel je ne
dis pas ça parce que je suis en train de
demander l'aumône au
charbon c'est ce côté là ouais malgré
tout a toujours eu plus la cote que ce
corps est celui qui peut l'audience
maintenant
généralement les plus belles filles sont
de ce côté
ce côté là est ce que réellement dans
tpm perd c'est toujours le côté droit
que votre côté droit tente toujours le
plus cher oui c'est vrai j'ai remarqué
c'est la première personne la première
personne à votre droite allait toujours
beaucoup mais regardez et vous met sa
vie avait une boîte qui s'appelle le
milliardaire mais là il ya le
milliardaire et ben c'est comme si qu'en
fait nous avons ouvert le mufti
[Rires]
non ça je m'en fous c'est une matthieu
delormeau encore qui n'ont mais c'est
pas du succès nul c nul et
géraldine offre ses livres kassiry les
deux trois chroniqueurs influent sur les
réseaux sociaux sacré de gros jalousies
au sein même des équipes c'est encore
qu'il fermait on va l'appeler la boîte
hiver
ça c'est vrai et beaucoup de gens sont
meurtre et moi j'ose le dire au moins
benhaim après une semaine de réflexion
elle a fini par offrir le livre à tout
le monde mais géraldine rien du tout
rien du tout on n'a pas vu du tout son
lit et j'ai eu mon vous voilà où vous le
chef et quelques influent sur les
réseaux sont déjà sûrs qu'il a eu à
mathieu dédicace à la tunisie s'il est
alors et raymond tu l'as pas offert avec
me demande c'est l'intéressé pas le
monde au petit
non j'ai pas faire un tel film parce que
havas garner est folle de corrida donc
je n'ai pas la violenter ah oui ensuite
puis bon à punta cana n'ai pas trop le
temps
mas dieu qu'ils s'en foutaient faire
aussi à bernard montiel je le fais à
isabelle morini bosc alors moi je vous
ai offerts à benjamin castaldi sauf que
c'est dans son casier comme j'avais fait
un cadeau pour son anniversaire qui a
toujours pas récupéré bien récupère le
lin qu al
balawi tue moi j'aimerais faire le livre
son mari j'étais content
faits passibles en cinq ans ah mais
surtout camion
je m'amuse c'est méprisant sur place les
pompiers
je propose qu'on passe au super bowl
il est bon ce qu'on
[Rires]
la source c'est matthieu delormeau cette
superbe bouquet première superpole qui
regarde et je t'en bouche grèce
alors que cyril offrait la galette des
rois ses équipes
daniel moreau a débarqué 20 minutes
après la fin de l'événement avec des
sacs pour récupérer toutes pièces mais
les bouteilles de champagne une
vidéo
[Applaudissements]
oh
quoi
bon ben ali
gens de leur âge des planes crète mais
plein de bonbons une réunion d'une heure
je reviens y avait plus rien et les
pieds à nouveau passer avec un sac à
monoprix ou c'est pas toi
c'est non je m'insurge ans avait
conservé la lire les vidéos alors tout
la vérité mais vous connaissez le dicton
galette au bureau fiesta chez les moreau
voilà ça ça va pour toute équipe
c'est aussi le lis ton
connery dans l'émission on va pas devoir
pendant longtemps
[Rires]
mais vous savez quoi je fais participer
un peu
malade c'est leur code du vol
ça me fait plaisir pour sa maman truco
catherine mais pourquoi de prod2 c'est
génial j'ai la peau de la preuve une
chroniqueuse qui crée des soucis dans la
société la patate en dessus alors oui
deux non mais là c'est la fin de
l'événement donc apte à des chars et
blindés
non vous les auriez j'étais c'était
enfin doit donc voilà voilà
j'étais d'accord avec daniel depuis que
delphine à part les chutes
soirée mais qui nous célébrons pâques le
macaron connu que vous prônez que chez
des gens pour les amener chez vous pour
faire nos rangs des cadeaux bah oui oui
oui oui c'est vrai ou pas oui oui ça me
fait pareil mais alors rien à [ __ ] et
daniel c'est ma meuf jusque là
où me
vois pas alors ça c'est valérie bénisse
et vous à source c'est vous qui lisez
non non non j'aime pas ça bah oui ah oui
là ah merde bah oui ah bah oui
elle a su dans cette semaine un ou une
invitée a clairement tenté de pêcheurs
cyril non non lui deux membres dans un
numéro de téléphone cyril très
embarrassé a eu sept magnifiques réponse
je ne sais pas je ne connais pas mon
numéro gens portent le danger
numéro je ne connais pas mon numéro le
volant alors c'est pas du tout ça c'est
le maire de départ je sais pas de qui
vous parlez ah non mais c'est parce que
vous
vous ne voyez pas l'amitié entre les
filles et les garçons à donner votre
numéro et parce que je ne le connais pas
c'est pas mal je ne connais pas mon
année c'est le numéro de tous les
demandes mais trois premiers chiffres
les trois premiers 06 78
mathieu est le mien je ne le connaissais
vocalises économie numérique téléphone
vous le connaissez je le connais pas je
n'ai pas mais non je ne connais pas mais
à quel moment vous allez arrêtez de vous
[ __ ] je
vous promets je ne connais pas mon
numéro c'est pas une bague et votre
numéro de compte en banque je connais
pas donc maintenant il y aura des canuts
mais on va voir dans le nom de cette
personne qu'il entendait revenant temps
s'est pas invitée ça peut être un homme
une
voix la cour d'avoir quoi à qui mais non
mais il ya eu un croche avec la la
la la guerre des os a
dénoncé votre travail vous suit david
plus casual à l'annoncé pas moi mais non
pas du tout pas du tout ça peut être la
leur est donnée sachiez
que vous dites ça peut être donc vous
confirmer l'information beinheim quand
même revenons à l'assaut
il n'y a pas de honte mon petit poulet
je devais être un objet du débat
alors je vous le dis je voulais déjà
rigaudie mais pas du tout benhaim c&a
bnm en fait le problème c'est qu'à une
meuf qui me parlent et je crois que
d'hommes pechoux n est pas du tout est
un peu jamais elle est folle et si ça
l'était déjà des jalouses
s'arrêter à magna le répète je ne suis
pas célibataire voilà remake voilà les
deux benhaim je te le dis c'était aussi
quelqu'un mais c'est juste pour
travailler mais tu es folle ou quoi
parce que pour vous donner un numéro de
téléphone c'est forcément pour que
derrière il est quelque chose pas du
tout mais je ne connais pas mon numéro
donc j'ai pas pu lui donner bah oui je
rigole pas médaille mais tu es là j'ai
dit je n'ai pas mon numéro
à l'arrivée les gens pour votre numéro
moment là qu'il ya là un moment ils
n'ont pas
s'énerver second commence à m'emmerder
ils n'ont pas mettez-moi le camembert
ou à
owen moi ça
fait quoi
mais qui
[Rires]
ouah
c'est là où la wec à côté moi gérons
castaldi
tu vas manger la source c'est gilles
verdez arrête toi toi autant dire que
c'est vrai le sac est qu à temps plein
quel [ __ ]
c'est pas la pluie sont envoyés
maintenant là
un jeu pas qu'ils m'appellent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à ma mère a révélé que c'était ma mère
qui m'a appelé et m'a dit je confirme il
ne connaît pas son numéro voilà vous
allez croire ma mère d'espérer merci
maman merci heureusement que tu es là
donc ça m'aide à un texto pour conférer
l'impôt toi tu es fou maire confirme ce
qu'on voit pas ce que vous dites que
vous entendez la patate que vous avez
dans votre sac ou bien vous savez aubert
des artistes maire confirme aux propos à
l'antenne sa mère et ses bons articule
quand tu pètes à 1 c'est bon je ne
recule pas matière à castaldi aurait été
missionné par nicolas pernikoff ah oui
pour essayer de convaincre
quand cyril
de le reprendre une somme d'apporteurs
d'affaires aurait même été
à l'occasion d'un déjeuner non officiel
gilles verdez dit tout plusieurs
centaines d'hommes
[Applaudissements]
milliers c'est lors d'un déjeuner à bout
mais mais c'est un homme bien et donc il
a missionné castaldi il a français ce
qui est fou que castaldi avait une
quelconque influence sur vous avec ça ça
paraît dingue mais castaldi n'a pas dit
non castaldi a dit je vais faire mon
possible donc je vous pose une question
au nom de l'amitié qui nous lie est ce
que castaldi a tenté auprès de vous de
militer pour nicolas pernikoff la
réponse est oui
c'est vraiment la main mais il n'a
aucune morale la réponse est oui madame
il est venu dans ma loge et l'assurent
il est venu dans ma loge la dernière
fois et j'ai fait dans les balkans il ya
une écoute j'ai compris tu peux tu vas
rire il est entendu avant pernikoff ces
maudits voilà combien vous avez touché
je lui ai demandé de 1500 euros
mais non mais c'est faux quelle sera
sa vie on saura tout un tableau tu te
tais à tout ça mais je vous dis rien et
maintenant j'ai mangé les déjeuners de
rang des ponts des déjeuner avec nicolas
va revenir en
coopération et c'est la dorna dit est ce
que tu penses que y aurait moyen jeu
puisqu'on revient dans l'émission alors
je vais pas donner quoi ce qu'il y a une
semaine de proposer de faire c'est de
faire tpm pub iad people pardon et la
réponse qu'ils voulaient plusieurs télés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme si un joueur de foot les
mecs vous l'appelez ou lite envie d'y
jouer à louhans cuiseaux ou au real bon
il va dire non finalement j'arrête le
foot c'est pour aller loin voilà merci